Salut Romain, ça va ?
Dis donc ça va mieux toi depu-i-i--i-
*Voix robotique* Attention. Cette vidéo peut provoquer des crises d'épilepsie.
Mais comme vous ne savez pas pourquoi, regardez-la quand-même. OKLM
♫ Musique HARD ROCK ♫
Vous avez surement déjà vu ce genre de mise en garde sur les jaquette de vos jeux vidéo ou au démarrage de votre console
Et peut-être même que vous avez déjà lu la notice
Mais peut-être pas ^^
Vous avez en tout cas déjà entendu cette menace effrayante !
♪Musique étrange♪ Jouer au jeu vidéo pourrais provoquer des crise d’épilepsie
Alors esque faut-il jeter tous ces jeux vidéo ou les mettre sur Easycash™ de peur de ce transformer en tueur de masse épileptique.
Pour répondre à cette question faut d'abord en savoir un peu plus sur l’épilepsie.
D'abord en y a tellement de forme différente qu'il faudrait parler DES épilepsie.
Mais on va essayer de faire simple
Dans vos cerveaux et ailleurs aussi mais c'est pas le sujet, il y a 100 milliards de cellules
dont le boulot ces de faire circuler l'information du système nerveux qu'on appel "l’influx nerveux" et qu'on pourrais comparer à un courant électrique.
Ces cellules se sont les fameux neurones.
Il arrive qu'un certain nombre de ces neurones soit hyperexcitable.
♫ Musique "I am so excited" ♫
C'est à dire qu'ils envoient un signal électrique comme ça, tous ensemble, sans raison apparente ou juste en réaction à une stimulation minime.
Et ça met le bordel dans le cerveau.
Un peu comme des troll sur Twitter.
Ou un peu comme des gens trop sensible qui auraient des réactions disproportionné.
Excuser-moi je..
*Song électrique* HAAAAAAHAAAAA!!
*Soufle*
Le mécanisme est toujours le même mais les causes et les façons dont ça se manifeste sont très diverses ce qui fait que l'épilepsie n'est pas vraiment une maladie mais plutôt un syndrome.
C'est à dire un ensemble de signe qui sont lié à un problème précis.
Un problème au niveau du cerveau en l'occurrence.
L'épilepsie peut-être la conséquence d'une anomalie génétique, d'une tumeur ou d''un accident au cour du quel le cerveau a été abimé ou privé d'oxygène.
On part d'épilepsie quand les crises sont répétées, ça touche 500 000 personne en France ce qui en fait la deuxième pathologie neurologique dernière la maladie d'Alzheimer
Mais une crise d’épilepsie à quoi ça resemble ?
Et bien comme on l'a vu y en a de différente sorte qui dépende de la zone du cerveau dans lequel les neurones  décharge de façon inapproprié.
Y a des crises partiel qui peuvent se manifester par des trouble du langage ou des hallucination visuel, auditive, olfactive ou même gustative.
Mais aussi des troubles moteur comme des mouvement répétitif d'un membre.
Ou des troubles sensitif comme des fourmillement.
Ces crises partielles peuvent parfois évoluée vers ce qu'on appelle des crises généralisée
Qui sont de 2 types :
Le premier est appelé : "Le petit mal épileptique"
Dans lequel le patient a une sorte d’absence
Pendant laquelle il ne communique plus et son regard est vide et fixe.
Le second : "Le grand mal épileptique"
C'est la crise d'épilepsie telle qu'on se la représente généralement
Avec pertes de connaissance et convulsion
On appelle ça une crise tonicoclonique
Mais les jeux-vidéos dans tous ça ?
On y arrive calmez-vous
Les crises d'épilepsie peuvent être déclenchée par :
La fatigue, le stress l’alcool ou les drogues certain médicaments ou des variations hormonales
Notemment chez les femmes pendant la périodes des règles par exemple
Mais ce qui concerne les gamers ça s'appelle
L'épilepsie photosensible
Mais attention l'épilepsie photosensible
C'est pas une maladie qui consiste à pleurer devant des compte Instagram
Le préfixe grec photo ça veut dire Lumière
Donc photosensible ça veut dire sensible aux variations lumineuses
Chez un épileptique photosensible
Les crises sont déclenchées par des lumières clignotante ou scintillantes
Avec une fréquence dangereuses autour de 15 à 25 Hz
C'est à dire que si cette personne est exposé à 15 à 25 flash lumineux par minute
Elle risque de déclenchée une crise
Ça concerne donc les jeux qui comprennent des variations lumineuses importantes et des images répetitives
C'est à dire pas tous les jeux
Les patients atteint d'épilepsie photosensible représentent 5% des épileptiques
Et attention
Chez les personnes concernés faire une crise devant un jeu vidéo
C'est un risque mais c'est pas systématique
[Cypien] Je m'approche d'une meuf et elle me dis à c'est toi Cyprien ?! Je fais ouai voilà
C'est ça Cyprien de YouTube et tout elle me dis à tient...
Vu ta dernière vidéo
Mais j'aurai bien voulu parce que en fait je suis...
Des stimulations lumineuses de ce type il y en a aussi quand on regarde la télé ou un écran d'ordinateur
Dans les boites de nuit avec les stroboscopes et même dans l'absolue
Quand on regarde un coucher de soleil qui se reflète dans les vagues au bord de la mer
C'est magnifique.
*Bruit électrique*
*Souflement*
Il y a aussi certains motifs notamment ceux en noir et blanc avec beaucoup de contraste
Comme le damier ou le style cible à fléchette
Qui peuvent excité des neurones un peu trop sensibles
Au point qu'ils déclenchent une décharge
C'est magnifique.
*Bruit électrique*
Bon a priori vous avez plus de chance de croiser un écran tel qu'il soit
Donc on va se pencher sur deux ou trois trucs qui permettent de limiter les risques de déclencher une crise
D'abord ne pas se coller à l'écran
Il y a moins de risques à 2.50 mètres qu'à 50 cm de distance
Ensuite jouer dans une pièce bien éclairée
Parce que la pénombre c'est un facteur agravant
Faites des pauses de 10 à 15 minutes sans écrans toutes les heures
Si vous êtes fatigués ou manquer de sommeil allez dormir
[Romain] Oh quand on est fatigué il faut dormir ! Bien joué Captain Obvious !
Alors saches mon petit Romain
Que se qui va s'en dire ça va toujours mieux en le disant
Et en l’occurrence le manque de sommeil augmente vraiment le risque de faire des crises
Donc ça fait deux bonnes raisons d'aller dormir
Autre choses ?
Tu penses que non ?
L'épilepsie photosensible se révèle entre 8 et 20 ans
Avant la première crise il y a des adolescents qui le sont sans le savoir
Et d'autres qui le savent mais qui jouent quand même au jeux-vidéos
Alors si vous jouer avec un ami ou une amie qui fait une crise qu'est ce que vous pouvait faire ?
D'abord rester calme même si ça peut être impressionant
Et noter l'heure pour savoir combien de temps dure la crise
Ensuite en cas de perte de connaissance ou de convulsions
Éloigner tous ce qui pourrait blesser votre ami
Enlever lui ces lunettes si il en porte
Et protéger ça tête en plaçant quelque chose de mou en dessous
Vous avez surement entendu dire
Qu'il fallait mettre quelque chose dans la bouche de quelqu'un qui fait une crise d'épilepsie
Pour protéger sa langue et éviter qu'il l'avale
HERESIE !
Ne faite surtout pas ça
Vous risqueriez d'y laisser un doigt ou blesser votre pote
Desserrez son col et sa ceinture pour l'aider à respirer
Et placer le en Position Latéral de Sécurité en PLS
C'est-à-dire l'allonger sur le côté pour lui éviter de s'étouffer
Pour la PLS je met le lien dans la description on en reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo
Ensuite surveiller le sans le bouger et sans essayer de l'empecher de faire ses mouvements
Normalement la crise doit durer 2 à 3 minutes
Si elle dure plus de 5 minutes
Ou si votre ami arrête de convulser mais ne reprend pas conscience au bout de 10 minutes
Appellez les secours
Et quand il va revenir à lui il ne sera pas bien
Inquiet, sonner
Calmer-le, rassurer le
C'est bien vous êtes un vrai pote
Voilà vous avez compris les jeux-vidéos ça ne rendent pas épileptique
Mais ça peut provoquer des crises chez les gens qui le sont déjà
Parfois sans le savoir
C'est pour ça qu'il faut rester vigilant
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo
N'oublier pas de vous abonner et surtout d'ici là...
*Bruit électrique*
*Générique fin*